Next concept is information hiding, developed by David Parnas. And
it has to do with encapsulating the capabilities that a particular module
has behind an abstract interface. After all, if the rest of the world
that's going to make use of that module only knows the abstract interface.
It gives you freedom later to change the implementation details without breaking
all the client programs. One key example of information hiding is if
you're dealing with a system that has access to many hardware devices,
hiding that access to the devices behind an abstract interface.
See if you can come up with some other good examples of places in
the system where you might like to hide information behind abstract interfaces.
Some typical examples include access to a database or some server some place,
the specifics of an algorithm or how you're implementing, a data structure.